the trouble with a lot of real world
experiments is that you can't have a
control group if you're researching say
how Riverbanks are affected by erosion
then either you have to observe the
erosion happening in the wild with lots
of messy variables like weather and
climate and Wildlife or you have to rely
on Tiny Scale Models or computer
simulations you can't take an actual
River let it erode its banks for a while
then stop the water rebuild everything
and just run it again with one thing
changed unless you build your own river
which is exactly what the University of
Sherbrooke in Canada has done
will you start the pumps please
so I've done a lot of studies in nature
on real Rivers you do get excellent
information but you can't pick out
specific variables and play with them we
built this with the idea that we can
study sediment transport on a scale that
kind of represents close to a small
River or creek the water starts in the
reservoir the pumps pump from the
reservoir and then it discharges into
the approach Channel which is made to be
very large so that we diminish any
turbulence that might be brought in
there by the pumps after that we have a
weir and then it arrives in the river
and goes down and that's where we do our
experiments from the river it falls over
an overflow into a sediment trap from
the sediment trap that goes back into
the raspberry it's a recirculating
system probably takes two or three
minutes for the water to recirculate so
it is all repeatable we can adjust the
pumps for a certain level have that one
day come back a week later and have the
same flow coming through the system you
have two 70 kilowatt pumps at the moment
we can have 8 hundred liters per second
and we have room for another pump okay
compared to the Mississippi this doesn't
look that big but here's how powerful it
is we anchored down a GoPro camera to
get those shots near the rear and the
water just blasted it away one of the
team here had to Wade in to save it
before it got washed into the base and
never to be recovered thank you so it
does a very good job of representing
small rivers and the processes that
happen here are much more related to say
a river than a small Laboratories
obviously in larger Rivers you have more
scales of turbulence but those scales
they should be similar in our size I've
seen the small scale model years ago one
of us did the bay model in California
it's a one to a thousand scale copy of
the San Francisco Bay which means it's
the size of a football field but the
1960s Engineers who built it had to
stick a load of copper strips into the
base to make the water behave like it
would at full scale by all accounts they
did really well particularly for before
computers but it's no comparison to
having a model that is closer to real
world size this summer we were looking
at erosion induced by a bank on
artificial bar we put in throughout the
world there's a problem in understanding
how much erosion is going to happen for
a given flood so as an engineer you want
to be able to run a model that will tell
you how much bank erosion you'll have in
the future we would also next year like
to start looking at ice cover and the
effect of ice on things like bank
erosion floods because ice related
flooding is a huge problem having a
river that where you can model ice would
be quite unique a lot of this work can
be done with computer simulations now
but the code for those simulations still
has to be validated and checked
somewhere like this and sometimes the
researchers here are working on things
that there is no computer model for
which surprised me I assume that
simulating water was pretty much a solid
problem but no there are still new
technologies that need to be tested and
one of them is up there getting the
aerial shots for this video to model
this River with a particle interaction
model would would take many days months
you years to run we have projects
involving large-scale particle image
philosometry this is a new technique
with a drone you'll take the water
surface and then you can have a velocity
which you can then relate to a discharge
how much water is moving through a
section of river per second and having a
method of measuring discharge without
actually going into the river is very
useful because it's very difficult to go
into these Rivers at high flows it's
very dangerous in fact the water surface
can be affected just by the general wind
but then that can influence or bias the
results of the flow we actually want to
measure unsure by the grand scales of
water parks and white water rafting
centers this isn't the biggest
artificial river in the world but it is
one that's built for research even if
that does mean that the team here
wouldn't let me bring my own inflatable
tube to ride down it nobody has ever
been down on an inflatable tube it's an
interesting idea but I don't think I
would advise it so I don't think I'll
advise it